Speaker 1: So I'm going to play some videos
for you of interviews with CPAC attendees,
Trump supporters at the Texas CPAC conference
that took place over the weekend.
Remember?
Why do we care about the attendees without
supporters?
The current Republican movement, which is
Trump ism, would just be Trump in a room yelling
and there would nobody there would be nobody
there.
So you have to understand that the attendees
give us insight into why Trump was even able
to win.
OK, so let's get right into it.
Let's get into some of these very, very strange
interviews.
Here we go.
Speaker 4: They should pay attention to their
children and what they say when they come
home from school.
Don't criticize.
Listen, if there's things that go against
what they've been teaching their children,
then they need to go to the school board
Speaker 1: meeting we all need.
OK, so understand that.
This is why Republicans win.
OK, these are people at the conference and
as wacky as their beliefs are, they understand
the way to win is you get involved in your
local school board.
Now, I'm not saying Democrats don't get involved
at the local school board, but what I am saying
is Republicans have been so much better than
Democrats for so long at working at all of
these levels really strongly.
They control all sorts of state and local
boards of education.
That's how they get this crazy nonsense in
school and into classrooms that they do know
what they're doing in that sense in a way
that I've not seen Democrats do.
Well, let's listen to some more.
Speaker 4: The books that our kids are being
forced to read so that we can have an honest
conversation with.
Right.
There's a way to fight back.
And the way to do it is use your words and
use your money.
Go to your schools.
Don't send your kid to an indoctrination camp
on college.
Use your money.
Email the alumni of the schools, email the
donors, say this is what they're teaching
my kids in school.
I think the way we can combat it is by parents
really knowing what's being taught in the
schools.
I don't know that passing laws do any good
at all.
Generally, a lot of the laws that are passed
are either ignored or creates anger.
But we have to get rid of the critical theory
being on school boards, getting into elected
offices so that you know what the curriculum
Speaker 3: is that is being taught.
Speaker 1: This is how they have successfully
done what Democrats have been unable to do
for a really long time.
So that's one side of CPAC.
This is like the old school CPAC.
These people actually do know how to organize
in the real world online stuff.
They're actually terrible.
They really are terrible with the online stuff,
but they know exactly what they're doing.
They're now here is the cartoonish side.
Here are some interviews.
Right Side Broadcasting Network did.
This is the other side and the wacky people
that show up.
Let's take a look here.
Speaker 5: Hey, how are you doing?
Hey, Mike.
Mike with Rightside.
Yeah.
So Latinos for Trump, right?
So talking about Latinos for Trump, what do
you think president is going to be saying
here?
You have Trump 2020 for sure.
He's going to be running here.
Absolutely.
I think so, yes.
What do you think his message is going to
support?
What do you want to hear him say the most
besides that he's running,
Speaker 4: that we are not going to let our
country falter?
Communism.
I was very excited when
Speaker 1: that is that.
Listen, we've been covering this for four
months, four years.
This is what the Republican Party now is,
what she wants to hear from Trump.
It's not about how am I going to put money
in your pocket?
How am I going to get you health care?
How are we going to fix infrastructure?
It's how are we going to stop communism?
There's no threat of communism in the United
States.
There's no there's no risk that the United
States will become a communist country.
Their messaging is nuts.
But these people seem to have accepted it
hook, line and sinker.
Speaker 4: President Trump started talking
about socialism because no one was having
that conversation, even though we were seeing
it happen.
And all of our communities, wow, no one was
having that conversation.
They didn't want to say call it what it is.
It's communism.
And then we have a lot.
Speaker 1: What's communism?
What is communism
Speaker 4: organizations here in the state
of Texas that our like our People's Project
or Texas Organizing Project.
It sounds, you know, the way that they word
it, you know, but it's worded in such a way
where you wouldn't say or think that that
is a communist walk and they are running communist
on the Democratic ballot here in the state
of Texas.
Speaker 1: So this woman is completely wrong
about the facts of everything that's going
on, but it's been very, very effective and
they don't care about policy.
So when we say, oh, at some point, don't they
have to get back to policy?
Not really, because if they can just go with
fear of communism, that doesn't exist, they
don't really need to go back to that.
Here's another example.
Next person they interviewed of they understand
the importance of going local.
Speaker 5: Thank you, Chad.
Appreciate it.
What?
Sure.
What are you.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I'm from California and I'm
an activist, and I believe in what we're saying
here about getting involved in stuff.
But I think we forget to mention that how
we're going to do that.
We need to get back into the neighborhoods
we need to do.
In California right now, we are organizing
precincts and voter registration.
You're not talking about voter registration.
Speaker 5: I think that's actually that's
a great point.
Speaker 1: I'm glad they get it, guys.
They get it.
And so as cartoonish as these people are.
They can keep winning stuff, they can keep
what they the local element here, they get
it.
Here's one more.
Here's a homeschooler that they ran into
Speaker 5: and you brought your daughter along
so so can talk about your experience tieback.
Why are you here?
What did you hope to get out of it?
And we're towards the end now.
So what are your final thoughts?
Speaker 6: Well, I'm absolutely blown away.
I mean, this is our first CPAC and I decided
to bring my I'm a homeschool mom, so I homeschool
my three kids.
And so this is basically part of their education
right now.
Speaker 1: Homeschooling, OK, the most common
reason that people homeschool in the US is
because they want a safe school environment
that's 25 percent.
Now, what does that mean?
They're not talking about physical safety.
When they mean safe, they mean safe from indoctrination
that they believe is taking place.
That's 25 percent of home schoolers say that's
why they're home schooling.
Twenty one percent of home schoolers are doing
it to teach kids their religious and moral
views.
These are overwhelmingly conservative Christians.
OK, that's the home schooling movement.
That's the element.
There's huge overlap between the Christian
homeschoolers and the anti taxers.
homeschoolers and the right wing conspiracy
theories.
So right away, hitting all the highlights
of these folks.
Let's continue the
Speaker 6: I brought Charlotte.
She's 14 with me.
It's it's been amazing.
I mean, I'm meeting so many great people.
I feel at home.
Finally, I'm from California, so it's a little
tough right there.
Speaker 1: Sometimes that's why she home schools.
She's because she wants her daughter around
people like the ones that go to CPAC.
Speaker 6: And I appreciate you guys so much
for all you do.
We actually can find the rallies and you can
find all the true news here.
So it's been wonderful.
Speaker 5: So so in Charlotte.
So you are fourteen years old, right.
And this is probably your first political
event.
Right.
So so what are your thoughts been on the last
couple of days?
Speaker 4: It's been insane.
It's been pretty overwhelming,
Speaker 6: but it's been really cool, like
seeing everyone and meeting everyone.
Speaker 1: I especially liked when Trump had
people chant lock her up about Hillary.
Speaker 5: So who who who is your favorite
person that you've met?
Have you met any Congress?
People, politicians.
Speaker 1: When Lauren Bobert said no vaccines,
I thought that was so proud.
I was so proud of that.
It was so great.
I mean,
Speaker 3: anybody like that we
Speaker 4: met Matt and Mercedes Schlapp.
No, really kind to us.
It was really cool to meet them.
Speaker 5: Amazing.
Like I said earlier, the great thing about
CPAC is that grassroots people, people who
just love this country.
Speaker 1: So there it is, really horrifying
stuff at CPAC.
But these people vote.
They won in 2016.
They almost won in twenty twenty.
And we have a really big uphill battle in
twenty, twenty two and twenty twenty four
upcoming.
After the break, we'll talk about the CPAC
straw poll winner and a bunch of other stuff.
We'll have more on this on the show's Instagram.
Find it at The David Pakman Show on Instagram.
Oh, by the way, follow me.
I showed people my eggplant over the weekend
on my Instagram David Pakman.
It's my first eggplant and you can find that
on my my Instagram.
Quick break.
Back after this.